I've always considered action directors  are like probably the greatest cinematic  directors all right even directors who  who like maybe don't just do action but  can do action beautifully like say like  Francis Ford Coppola in the helicopter  sequence of Apocalypse Now  I mean that's just to me choreography  the the Pinnacle of movie making all  right that sequence and if I'm I've  never really done that before so if I'm  gonna throw my hat in the ring I'm gonna  like throw it in I want to throw it in  with the big boys I don't want to be  okay I want to be as good as them if not  better not saying I am but that's the  goal  [Applause]  um and at the end of it all since I know  action scenes and I know it gets me off  all right then it's like if I didn't do  it I would know it all right and I was  like okay I guess I'm not as good I'm  not as good as I think I am stick to the  dialogue